Do genetics tell a person about the best diet?
No, so genetics don't tell a person about the best diet,
but genetics do tell us if the person could have issues
with gluten, could have issues with dairy,
and some of the other,
other foods that could be related to those things.
So if I have a gene defect that's related to the gluten,
that is the gluten genes,
I have an increased chance of having gluten sensitivity,
or I have an increased the other defect for the celiac gene,
you have an increased risk of having celiac.
Doesn't mean you're going to remember gene defects,
doesn't mean you absolutely have that issue.
It means you have a defect on that,
and you have a greater chance of having a problem with that,
doesn't mean you're going to.
So it gives us, that's why I speak
throughout the whole genetic course about it gives you clues,
it gives us clues.
So if I have defects on that pathway,
we make recommendations in our genetic summary,
in genetic action step sheets,
that maybe it'd be a good idea to decrease gluten,
or to decrease dairy based upon your genes.
It doesn't mean that you have antibodies to gluten,
or antibodies to dairy.
In order to find out that,
you'd have to run an antibody test,
and we recommend the Cyrex test.
So the Cyrex test measures antibodies for different foods.
So remember, genetic picture of somebody
doesn't tell us a condition.
The genetic picture tells us some precursors
to what could lead to conditions,
and precursors that could lead to just some issues.
So it's not going to tell us what's the best perfect diet
for somebody, it's going to tell us some clues.